[موسيقى] ميناء سهى في شمال عمان منشأة ضخمة بشكل مذهل تقع في موقع استراتيجي في وسط طرق التجارة العالمية بين الشرق والغرب ، كما أنها في قلب إستراتيجية شهر لتعزيز قطاع الخدمات اللوجستية بها ، كيف حالك صباح الخير صباحًا ، كيف حالك جيد ، مارك آيلاند هو الرئيس التنفيذي لميناء سوهو والمنطقة الحرة ، لقد أتى إلى عمان منذ خمس سنوات وشهدها خلال الأوقات الصعبة ، لذلك كان لدينا أزمة نفطية لدينا جائحة وما زلنا نكبر كل مرة عام واحد ونحن ننمو كل عام منذ أن كنت هنا ، لذا فهي قصة كبيرة من نجاح الاستثمارات الجديدة والأشياء الجديدة القادمة إلى الميناء والمنطقة الحرة ، كما يقول ، لقد وصل 68 مليون طن من البضائع عبر الميناء هذا العام ، 7 من أصل 10 منتجات ستشاهدها في هذا البلد تأتي عبر ميناءنا [موسيقى].
موانئ المياه العميقة والمناطق الحرة ، يجب أن نكون
في صدارة اللعبة من حيث التكنولوجيا
من حيث التوسع من
حيث الأفراد وكذلك ،
لذا
فإن موانئنا هي ميناء عالي الكفاءة للغاية
تعرفه
في الوقت
الذي تعلم فيه أننا صنفنا  في المراكز العشرة الأولى على
مستوى العالم من حيث الكفاءة
[الموسيقى]
وتستفيد الشركات من تلك
الكفاءة
مثل spmp التي تصنع
الأنتيمون والمعادن الثمينة
والذهب ، تشتري الشركة المواد الخام من جميع
أنحاء العالم
وتعالجها ثم تشحن
المنتج النهائي ،
كل شيء يحدث بشكل صحيح  هنا في
المنطقة الحرة في ميناء سوهو ،
يدور عملنا حول الأنتيمون ولكن يتعلق
أيضًا بالخدمات اللوجستية ، يتعلق الأمر
بإيصال المنتجات إلى الموقع وإيصال
البضائع النهائية
إلى العميل.
وبدأت الإنتاج في عام 2019 ،
تتمتع الشركة بميزة ضريبية كبيرة للعمل
هنا
في عمان ، حيث تسمح المنطقة الحرة لشركة spmp
باستيراد تلك المركزة  te عالميًا
وتصدير منتجاتنا دون الحاجة إلى
التعامل مع جميع الضرائب وعبء الاستيراد
والتصدير
المرتبط عادةً بإحضار المنتجات من
وإلى بلد ما ،
فنحن نقدم لك فقط متجرًا شاملاً حتى
تأتي إليّ وأنا '  سنأخذك خلال
عملية كل ما تحتاجه من تصاريح
أه بدء شركتك والوصول
إلى الغرفة إلى وزارة
التجارة للحصول على تصريح بيئي خاص
بك ،
لقد أتيت إلينا للتو وسنساعدك
خلال العملية برمتها